Public Sénat en partenariat avec le
Centre national du livre vous présente
au bonheur des livres
[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans l'émission
littéraire de Public Sénat au bonheur
des livres dans une interview Carla
Bruni avait dit à quoi reconnaît-on sa
soeur lorsqu'elle rentre dans la pièce
elle n'a encore rien dit et déjà elle
vous énerve on sait depuis Abel et Caïn
que les rapports fraternels ou sororo
sont un mélange d'amour et de rivalité
et c'est de ça dont nous allons parler
notamment ce soir dans une émission que
nous avons intitulé Les Innocents les
innocents parce que les frères dont nous
allons parler sont des êtres vulnérables
coupé du monde parfois et en tout cas
touchant et nous allons faire avec deux
écrivains un écrivain consacré Jérôme
Garcin et un écrivain débutant débutant
en tout cas dans le métier de romancier
Raphaël arrangement soir ça vous êtes un
chanteur adulé et vous avez déjà publié
deux recueils de nouvelles qui ont
d'ailleurs été remarqué mais c'est la
première fois vous publiez un roman
avalanche aux éditions Gallimard qui est
le récit pendant quelques semaines de la
vie de deux adolescents dans un
pensionnat pour ghostburich en Suisse
mais on va commencer avec Jérôme Jérôme
bonsoir bonsoir Denis vous dirigez
depuis plus d'une trentaine d'années et
les pages culture de l'Obs et le Masque
et la plume la célèbre émission critique
de critique de France Inter mais à côté
de cette vie journaliste vous avez une
vie d'écrivain consacrée je l'ai dit
vous avez publié trentaine de livres de
récits de romans décès de biographie de
livres d'entretien et en cette rentrée
de janvier vous vous êtes vous avez
publié mais fragile
chez Gallimard qui est un livre
bouleversant quoi que votre écriture
soit retenue et pudique et qui est un
champ funèbre pour votre mère et pour
votre frère disparu l'un et l'autre à
quelques semaines d'intervalle un champ
funèbre qui est en même temps un champ
d'amour et un éloge de très touchant de
la différence on va commencer par votre
mère parce que
elle a été au fond poursuivi par le
malheur et la difficulté pendant toute
son existence elle a perdu votre frère
jumeau et vous étiez sous vos yeux il a
été fauché par une voiture lorsqu'il
avait 6 ans quelques temps après elle a
perdu votre père qui avait une
quarantaine d'années auxquelles a été
unie par un amour incandescent les
lettres d'amour de votre père vous
publiez son magnifique et pourtant elle
n'a jamais perdu ni son courage ni sa
joie de vivre ni son émerveillement
devant l'oeuvre du créateur j'utilise
cette expression à dessin parce qu'elle
était profondément chrétienne
d'où venait cette incroyable force d'âme
de son tempérament ou bien est-ce que
c'est dans sa foi qu'elle puisait sa
force
je pense que d'abord sa nature était une
nature incroyablement résistante
physiquement mentalement moralement le
et c'est vrai que très longtemps je me
suis dit pouvoir supporter de perdre un
enfant mon jumeau à moins de 6 ans dans
un accident qui est qui était un
traumatisme pour nous tous puisqu'on y a
assisté on a vu ce corps d'enfant
soulevé par une voiture qui ne s'arrête
pas
mon père était éditeur et dirigé elle
est puffes et presse universitaires de
France pure intellectuelle
je veux dire par la pas du tout sportif
il a fait le choix à ce moment-là après
la mort de Olivier de mon jumeau
il a fait le choix de faire peut-être
l'activité de sport le plus à risque
quelle équitation
il est mort de ça 10 ans après d'une
chute de cheval le cheval s'est emballé
dans une forêt à Rambouillet et et là
encore ma mère était là elle a supporté
ça
et je pense que pour répondre à votre
question qu'il y avait évidemment
d'abord sa nature et ensuite cette fois
qui était une fois
rayonnante débordante
pour moi presque un peu inexplicable je
les vois encore aller
son copain Michael Lonsdale et elle à
Saint Séverin comme un couple à la
Pennel comme ça qui allait et j'y
ajouterai une troisième chose qui était
quand même chez elle une
un amour de la vie qui passait aussi par
l'amour de l'art elle était peintre elle
était restauratrice de tableau et la
peinture italienne et là et la beauté de
l'art en faisait pour moi une femme
assez assez surhumaine et alors elle
connaît les tragédies qu'on vient
d'évoquer et puis elle est elle s'est
aussi occupée toute sa vie de votre
frère cadet Laurent qui était atteint
d'une maladie génétique qui a été
diagnostiquée assez tard et qui frappe
toute votre famille et qui quand elle
s'exprime elle c'est moi qui vous
compris mais quand elle s'exprime elle
sait pas exprimée chez vous quand elle
s'exprime et s'exprimer chez votre frère
elle se traduit par des degrés divers
une forme de déficience intellectuelle
et où de maladies mentales et alors dans
le livre on vous décrivez le soin
qu'elle a pris de votre frère d'une
manière qui est vraiment bouleversante
mais en même temps on ne peut pas ne pas
se dire que ça a dû peser sur elle
évidemment mais et la maladie étant le X
fragile
qui est une anomalie génétique du
chromosome X
qu'elle a transmis et qui a des formes
très variées moi je suis un malade sain
un porteur sain mais
je l'ai transmis
c'est une maladie qui est là deuxième
cause quand même de déficience mentale
après la trisomie 21
et qui
se transmet évidemment de génération en
génération c'est la première cause
héréditaire contrairement à l'autisme ou
à la trisomie
ça passe d'une génération et plus ça
descend dans les générations plus le mal
s'accroît
ce qui fait que moi j'ai été
diagnostiqué
en 2010 je l'ai transmis à ma fille pas
mes garçons qui sont à qui j'ai donné
mon y mais à ma fille qui elle-même la
transmis à sa fille à ma petite fille et
c'est un cauchemar un cauchemar et ma
mère et Laurent étaient mon frère cadet
était
particulièrement atteint avec des
difficultés d'élocution nombreuses une
impossibilité évidemment d'avoir une vie
sociale ne parlons même pas de ce
qu'avait pu être sa vie scolaire et ma
mère le regardait comme un être
différent
pas handicapé après la mort de ma mère
j'ai eu en charge immédiatement
évidemment mon frère cadet dont j'ai
demandé la tutelle à la justice et après
je suis allé vers la MDPH que la maison
du handicap
pour que son statut soit reconnu mais ça
elle ne l'avait pas fait dire que et
d'ailleurs lui-même ou le dite
refuse ce statut il y a une scène
bouleversante dans laquelle on voit sa
fulgurance et dans laquelle vous essayez
de le mettre dans une maison pour qu'on
prenne soin de lui et lui refuse en
disant mais non je suis pas ça trop de
handicapés ici alors ce frère il est
inadapté au monde il est perdu dans ses
pensées il communique difficilement il a
des gestes répétitifs mais en même temps
c'est un peintre merveilleux mais en
même temps il sert la messe mais en même
temps il a des fulgurances
d'enterrement de sa mère je me suis dit
peut-être que c'est faux que c'était la
déclaration d'amour que vous ne lui
aviez pudique que vous ne lui aviez pas
fait de son vivant que à laquelle
peut-être il n'aurait pas eu accès
d'ailleurs c'est pas forcément mais que
vous aviez envie de lui faire une fois
sa disparition une fois une fois disparu
vous avez dit au début que c'était
effectivement un livre funèbre puisque
ce sont deux morts consécutives mais
c'est d'abord un champ d'amour vous
connaissez ce mot
magnifique de du philosophe Alain
et
les les morts veulent vivre ils veulent
vivre et vivre en nous en nous tous moi
c'est une conviction que j'ai profonde
je reprends le titre volontiers
d'Emmanuel Bert là présence des morts et
tous mes livres ne tiennent qu'à ce fil
c'est à dire ce chant d'amour au mien
parce que je ne supporte pas l'oubli je
ne supporte pas le saccage de l'oubli je
ne supporte pas quand j'ai fait un livre
sur mon jumeau renversé sous mes yeux
par une voiture encore une fois on
n'avait pas six ans je lui ai consacré
un livre sur cette couverture blanche il
y avait simplement Olivier c'était
l'idée qu'un enfant qui n'a pas pu vivre
qui reste
mon jumeau lui consacré un livre c'est
faire en sorte que même un enfant de 6
ans peut exister moi je crois que les
vies sont malheureusement très souvent
brèves mais très souvent pleine d'autres
livres que j'ai consacré à des gens qui
ne sont pas de ma famille dieu merci
c'est à dire Gérard Philipe dans le
dernier rivière du sud Jean de la ville
de Miremont Jean Prévost premier
résistant mort à 40 ans au pied du
Vercors
tous ces gens-là ont eu des vies très
brèves mais très pleines et moi dans
tous ces cas là où Jacques lucéran s'est
aveugle
résistant lui aussi
je ne veux ni accepter l'oubli dans
lesquels on les a mis c'était le cas de
prévaut de luceron et des autres ni pour
les miens accepter qu'ils ne vivent pas
qu'il ne continue pas à vivre et c'est
vous avez raison ce livre là est d'abord
un champ d'amour à ma mère
merveilleusement et aussi à ce frère
votre récit s'achève par quelle belle
vie il a dû avoir et comme il a été donc
c'est bien heureux les pauvres en esprit
mais vous c'est une antiphrase quelle
belle ville a eu ou c'est ce que vous
pensez vous pensez que c'est comme ça
qu'il l'a vécu c'est ce que je veux
croire évidemment que non évidemment que
non c'était il a dû il était
terriblement solitaire
la mort de ma mère a été un traumatisme
puisqu'il est mort quelques vraiment
quelques mois après
et non je ne crois pas je veux je veux
croire que il ressemble davantage au
tableau lumineux
diaprès joyeux qu'il a peint que qu'une
vie de
se fragile lourd ce livre s'inscrit vous
l'avez dit vous les avez évoqué si vous
avez vous êtes vous avez vous êtes vous
avez entrepris quelque chose qui n'a je
crois pas d'exemple enfin en tout cas
j'ai cherché dans ma mémoire sans
trouver qui est de constituer de livres
en livre un récit sur votre père sur
votre frère jumeau un récit sur vos
super et maintenant un récit sur votre
mère et sur votre frère cadet un
mémorial
un mausolée à la présence des morts que
vous venez d'évoquer de votre famille et
je dois dire que ce récit-là m'est
fragile
est une magnifique lamentation
sur la vie bienheureuse et sur la mort
douloureuse la disparition douloureuse
de votre mère et de votre frère il
s'inscrivent dans cette dans ce dans
cette suite de livres qui composent un
ensemble auquel je renvoie le lecteur on
va poursuivre avec Raphaël
avalanche chez Gallimard alors vous êtes
sur un autre registre Raphaël
il vous arrive d'être et léger hâte mais
c'est plutôt souvent le registre de la
farce qui ne veut pas dire que ce ne
soit pas un livre sensible donc c'est un
roman d'initiation un roman d'éducation
deux frères Léonard saison et Nicolas
Douzon se retrouve à la fin des années
par suite d'une série de ruptures
familiales sur laquelle on va revenir
dans un pensionnat Suisse pour gosse de
riche et de puissants ils arrivent dans
cette dans ce pensionnat par suite d'une
série de ruptures familiales enfin d'une
principale d'un accident de voiture je
l'ai perdu père aussi oui mais je dirais
qu'il y a une scène primitive qui a un
accident de voiture qui a coûtait la vie
à leur mère dans lequel l'aîné était et
pas le petit pas son petit frère et à la
suite de cet accident la famille vole en
éclat le père
noyé sous le chagrin ou fuyant
ne sachant que faire de ce chagrin part
pour être professeur de physique en
Amérique du Sud et là c'était deux
enfants sous la garde de leur vieille
grand-mère et qui pour qu'ils ont
beaucoup d'affection mais à qui ils en
veulent énormément d'être une vieille
dame tout simplement de d'avoir une
vieille dame qui vient de chercher à la
sortie de l'école et de c'est d'ailleurs
vous faites de cette parce que en effet
le père est parti il va réapparaître à
la fin du roman comme figure tutélaire
et protectrice mais le point fixe de
deux frères c'est cette grand-mère cette
babouchka russe et juive dont vous
faites un portrait de temps mais quand
même un portrait à la Manche clou de
Cohen c'est-à-dire elle est sympathique
elle est temps mais elle est
extraordinairement envahissante et et
elle est moquée en quelque sorte d'une
manière très tendre ils ont ah moi je
trouve que c'est assez dur même la
moquerie qu'ils ont vis-à-vis de leur
grand-mère je trouve qu'ils ont une
grande ils ont une cruauté parce que
mais vous pas à moi non pas du tout mais
moi je suis je suis pas exactement ces
deux personnages je dirais que je suis
entre les deux
mais vous vous la décrivez d'une manière
qui est extrêmement touchante avec son
accent et ses manies et c'est oui elle
est très comme ça encombrée
embarrassante c'est un pensionnat pour
ultra riche donc tous les gens ont des
belles Patricia qui viennent tous les
élèves qui viennent chercher en voiture
de sport et eux ils ont une vieille dame
encombré de sacs plastiques avec de la
langue de boeuf ou des choses comme ça
parce qu'elle a toujours peur de manquer
avec la guerre et un accent à couper au
couteau elle a beau habitait depuis
depuis 50 ans en France elle parle
toujours avec un accent comme si comme
si elle venait du stettle quoi et il lui
en veulent il lui en veulent
mettre encombrantes et lui en veulent
surtout de ne pas être leur mère quoi
surtout de qu'on puisse penser que c'est
elle leur mère voilà alors dans ces deux
frères le premier le plus jeune qui a 12
ans Nicolas est un génie musical c'est
un enfant prodige mais il est lui aussi
envoie la discussion qu'on vient d'avoir
avec Jérôme il est lui aussi différent
il est étrange il est perché il est dans
son monde il est inadapté au monde des
autres et notamment à la cruauté du
monde des adolescents oui c'est pas un
génie du piano il apprend quoi il a une
bourse pour éventuellement étudier avec
un très bon maître et peut-être devenir
pianiste parce qu'en fait les les places
sont tellement limitées que même un très
grand pianiste à 12 ans peut ne plus
l'être à 16 ans quoi mais on a un espoir
qui le devienne et il est encore dans
l'enfance c'est à dire dans la pensée
magique il pense encore que il peut
communier avec sa mère grâce à des
cailloux que sa grand-mère lui a donné
il pense encore à une espèce de d'idée
que l'univers prend soin de tout il est
croyant il est pieux sa mère elle-même
croyante et donc il est tenu par quelque
chose une pensée religieuse et magique
et le grand frère au contraire c'est
ne crois plus en rien depuis cet
accident finalement et il a une pensée
cynique dure il essaye d'endurcir son
frère et de
le faire basculer dans le monde des
adultes finalement ils sont dans deux
mondes c'est pareil quoi un qui est
encore dans le monde de l'enfance et
l'autre qui est dans le crépuscule de
l'enfance et déjà dans le conformisme la
moquerie le sinistre de l'adolescence et
c'est grand ce grand frère Léonard celui
qui a 16 ans alors lui en effet il
cultive le cynisme punk il découvre le
sexe la violence la drogue il découvre
aussi une forme de lâcheté à l'égard de
son propre frère qui n'arrive pas à
protéger
il le supporte difficilement ou au sens
à la fois anglo-saxon et français du
terme mais et puis il a une immense
violence en lui qui contraste
complètement je dois dire avec l'image
qu'on se fait de l'auteur
en douceur en tendresse et envisage
angélique donc je me suis demandé si
c'était une espèce de d'autres mois de
contre moi dans 6 mois d'anti-héros pour
vous ou s'il y avait quand même une part
de vous moi j'ai l'impression qu'il y a
une part de moi je dirais que moi je
sais pas très bien
souvent quand on écrit on s'aperçoit de
quoi on parlait à la fin du livre
peut-être quelque chose comme ça j'avais
pas comme un thème que je voulais
aborder mais j'ai l'impression que je
suis un peu entre ces deux frères quoi
entre celui de 12 ans qui a sa pensée
magique et celui de 16 ans qui a une
violence qui a une colère en lui mais
qui est quand même racheté par quelque
chose c'est un personnage très dur mais
il est racheté par la tendresse qu'il a
vis-à-vis de son frère je trouve et puis
on le comprend enfin
moi j'aime bien c'est c'est faille mais
entre les deux tout ça ça se passe donc
à la fin des années 80 au moment de la
chute du mur qui est comme une métaphore
de ce qui se passe pour ces deux frères
le livre s'appelle avalanche donc
cet événement tellurique qui bouleverse
et chamboule tout est-ce que c'est la
mort de la mère qui est celle de ce
point de rupture c'est avalanche ou bien
est-ce que c'est l'adolescence est-ce
que c'est l'adolescence qui pour tout un
chacun qu'il y ait ou pas des événements
tragiques et ce moment de mutation
peut-être je pense que oui je pense que
le fait de le situer au moment de la
chute du mur de Berlin c'était déjà
parce que moi j'avais mes repères
d'adolescence à ce moment là j'avais
j'avais 14 ans donc je pouvais pouvoir
le décor et le et bien le ressentir et
ensuite j'aimais bien l'idée que au fur
et à mesure que le monde se libère
Pinochet balayé les tchéosescu sont
exécutés comme des chiens dans la cour
d'une caserne de prison le mur de Berlin
tombe et eux leur enfermement se
resserre au fur et à mesure que le
se libère et en même temps ils sortent
de l'enfance oui mais pour revenir sur
le sur l'adolescence oui je trouve que
la métaphore de la Balanche elle est
elle est assez parlante parce que il y a
cette idée qu'on est pris dans un dans
un mouvement qu'on peut plus arrêter qui
est le le l'entrée dans l'âge adulte et
qu'on a une perte de repères qu'on a une
inversion des polarités on sait pas où
est le haut où est le bas et on se
retrouve à creuser sans savoir si on va
vers la lumière ou si on va vers
l'obscurité je trouve que c'est assez
ça raconte un peu l'adolescence quoi le
chanteur s'appelle Raphaël mais l'auteur
de romans a repris son patronyme à Roche
il est revenu à son identité officiel
est-ce que ça veut dire que vous êtes
plus près le romancier plus près de vous
que le chanteur ou c'est de des masques
dans les deux cas ce sont des masques
dans les deux cas
je pense qu'on se dévoile beaucoup plus
dans des livres c'est un rapport
sûrement beaucoup plus intime parce que
on a beaucoup plus d'espace parce qu'on
met tellement de souvenirs de choses
personnelles alors que les chansons ça
reste plus énigmatiques j'ai
l'impression
ensuite c'est quand même assez
quand j'ai pris mon nom de chanteur
j'avais 23 ans j'avais envie de voir de
pas voir mon nom comme je l'avais vu à
l'école depuis que j'étais petit j'avais
honte à vous parents
c'est exactement et ensuite il y avait
l'idée un peu de quand on est romancier
là
pas vraiment j'avais plutôt l'envie
d'être comme une génération spontanée de
pas avoir de parents quoi devenir de
nulle part et ensuite quand on
effectivement en ayant vieilli un petit
peu
il y a l'idée de reprendre son nom parce
que les livres sont tellement marqués
dans la ce que la généalogie les lignes
de failles des choses qui se répercutent
de donc ce serait presque une trahison
ne pas mettre le nom et en plus tout
simplement cette série blanche ce serait
ridicule simplement de mettre un prénom
alors que ça marcherait pas Jérôme je
l'ai dit vous êtes écrivain mais vous
êtes aussi critique et alors oubliez que
vous êtes l'un des rude chez Gallimard
c'est un pur hasard et qui comment vous
avez lu le livre le premier roman de
Raphaël d'abord d'abord Raphaël est très
très énervant bien sûr avoir tous ces
dons là c'était c'est voilà chanteur
écrivain moi j'étais très sensible
d'abord en deux mots mais aux nouvelles
je trouve qu'il a qui était un jour
totalement délaissé aujourd'hui ou
malmener ou mal il en a fait un art pur
et ce livre là moi il m'a il m'a
beaucoup touchée j'ai pensé à du à du
Cocteau moderne
cette peinture de l'adolescence est une
justesse c'est ce qui est peut-être de
plus dur à faire plus que l'enfance pour
moi peindre littéralement l'adolescence
et et moi ce que j'ai aimé dans le livre
évidemment particulièrement c'est la
lecture que j'en ai faite si j'ose dire
il y a pour moi c'est pas deux
adolescents c'est le même chacun avec sa
face chacun avec ses démons chacun avec
ses aspirations et quand on les réunit
dans sa lecture ce qui a été mon cas ça
devient peut-être un livre encore plus
plus juste sur l'adolescence que je ne
le disais auparavant on va poursuivre
cette conversation avec un lecteur ou en
l'occurrence une lectrice Salomé qui a
une question pour Raphaël
Salomé on vous écoute
[Musique]
bonjour 9 ans et j'habite en
Eure-et-Loir j'ai ouvert il y a deux ans
maintenant le compte Instagram biblio
sweelow sur lequel vous pouvez retrouver
mes derniers coups de cœur mes avis
l'ivresse en photo et en vidéo avec des
lectures très variées beaucoup de
littérature dites classiques des romans
graphiques des BD etc
aujourd'hui je voulais vous parler d'un
classique parmi des classiques ma
rencontre avec Alexandre Dumas c'est un
auteur
gargantuesque qui a écrit plus de 646
livres ici on est avec la Reine Margot
l'histoire débute en 1572 après le
mariage de la Reine Margot avec le roi
Henri de Navarre il faut savoir que
c'est un livre qui peut impressionner
par le niveau de la langue mais les
joues de verbales sont incroyables c'est
absolument bien écrit c'est très beau à
lire on a presque envie de lire à voix
haute tellement des passages sont très
très beaux donc foncez lire ce classique
parfois ça peut rebuter de se lancer
dans des des beaux pavés comme ça mais
vraiment ça vaut le coup
bonjour Raphaël Haroche vous signez à
valanche et Gallim
ARD j'avais une petite question
concernant le chapitre 20 sur lequel
apparaît une photographie d'une jeune
femme en terrasse vous présentez cette
jeune femme comme la mère des deux
personnages principaux les deux frères
dans les remerciements vous dites que
c'est une photo qui vous est très chère
je savais que j'allais pouvoir vous
poser la question donc je me suis pas
renseignée avant j'aimerais savoir ce
que représente pour vous cette
photographie qui est cette femme
pourquoi est-ce que vous l'avez
introduit dans votre livre voilà est-ce
que vous pouvez nous expliquer pourquoi
cette photo dans ce dans ce chapitre oui
oui je peux l'expliquer c'est une photo
de ma tante de la sœur aînée de ma mère
qui a été prise en photo chez lip par
quartier Bresson je ne sais pas dans les
années 60 quelque chose comme ça c'est
une photo cher à mon cœur parce que ma
tante est morte il y a longtemps et que
la photo est magnifique et votre tente
aussi est magnifique je suis d'accord et
en regardant cette photo je voyais qu'on
ne voyait pas bien son visage qui avait
quelque chose on voyait juste ses
cheveux son allure quoi et j'imaginais
que pour ses enfants qui pouvaient se
RAC à cette photo comme un comme un
souvenir il y a un doute sur l'identité
qui puisse se raccrocher à la pensée
magique du du
petit Léonard votre obscinaliste va être
très très intéressé confusion entre la
tente et la mer cette émission s'achève
mais avant que nous nous quittions je
voulais que vous partagiez avec nous vos
coups de cœur de la semaine attention
c'est satisfait ou remboursé il faut
vraiment que le lecteur soit heureux du
choix que vous allez lui suggérer on va
commencer par vous Jérôme un gros livre
pas cher
aux éditions bouquins dans la collection
bouquin et aux éditions bouquins qui
s'appelle zone limite qui est pas le
meilleur titre qui soit derrière mon
avis de Jean-Paul Kaufman
qui rassemblant Jean-Paul Kaufman ex
otage français à Beyrouth au Liban au
milieu des années 80
on parle Raphaël et qui depuis qu'il a
trois ans trois ans au otage dans
l'obscurité dans une souffrance qu'on
imagine et qui depuis fait ses grands
voyages dans des lieux qui sont aussi
absolument à pénétrables souvent aussi
des formes de joules de Kerguelen
jusqu'à long good jusqu'à la prison de
Napoléon et donc tous ces livres sont
rassemblés il y a aussi remonter la
Marne c'est magnifiquement écrit c'est
très émouvant quand on sait évidemment
le parcours de Kaufman et encore une
fois vous avez six ou sept livres dont
un petit merveilleux sur Bordeaux dans
un même volume c'est pas cher et c'est
une promesse de promenade absolument
incroyable à Bordeaux parce qu'il est
grand amateur de vin et vous Raphaël
quel est votre choix votre goût de coeur
et bien alors c'est pas du tout récent
c'est pas grave c'est un livre de Pérec
qui s'appelle W ou le souvenir d'enfance
que je viens de lire et qui m'a fait
beaucoup penser à ce que vous disiez sur
la lutte contre la disparition comme ça
sur le le souvenir qui s'effacent et de
de
c'est un récit en deux parties et en
parallèle ses propres souvenirs
d'enfance qui sont très fragmentaires
c'est vraiment une lutte contre l'oubli
parce que sa mère a été déportée son
père est mort le premier jour de la
guerre dans un dans un bombardement et
il ne se souvient quasiment rien de son
enfance souviens juste qu'il a dit au
revoir à sa mère sur un quête de Lyon et
qu'il était on n'est pas la Croix-Rouge
et en parallèle il y a un espèce de
récit qui ressemble à une île au début
imaginaire qui était le souvenir
d'enfance qui se recréer de son enfance
et qui devient des sortes des jeux
d'Olympiades fascistes où les enfants
justement quand ils grandissent son
premier la mort et le livre est très
mystérieux très puissant et puis en ce
moment je lis tous les livres de Perret
que j'ai une passion pour chaque ligne
de Pérec je crois que je suis amoureux
de chaque mot c'est eux qui suivent
cette émission savent que nous aussi on
adore alors nous au bonheur des livres
on a choisi cette semaine Nicolas
d'Etienne dehors dictionnaire amoureux
du mauvais goût c'est un écrivain
journaliste assez fantasque et là il a
réuni toute une série de souvent très
drôle mais qui vont de l'andouillette à
Richard Clayderman à la fois des mauvais
goûts qu'il a lui-même et les mauvais
goûts que la société
déteste et que lui dont il fait l'éloge
schnock qui est une revue fantastique
revue chaque numéro est toujours
exceptionnel et là c'est sur Louis de
Funès Manu Dibango
papa groove comme on avait surnommé star
du jazz français ou franco-africain
personnage très sympathique qui a
disparu lors du covid c'est une
conversation avec quiche Bigot qui est
passionnante et enfin ça c'est presque
un choix très personnel de ma part
Michka Assayas qui est un excellent
critique musical et qui raconte sa
génération qui est la mienne à travers
des chansons des musiques avec des
playlists et donc si vous voulez
parcourir disons des années 60 à
aujourd'hui à travers la musique est-ce
qu'elle évoque c'est ce livre que vous
devez lire voilà
cette émission maintenant et
véritablement terminée merci de l'avoir
suivi merci à Jérôme et à Raphaël merci
à Salomé vous pouvez nous revoir sur le
psy de Public Sénat ou sur les la
plateforme de votre plateforme préférée
et puis nous nous retrouvons la semaine
prochaine à moins que d'ici là nous ne
nous soyons croisés dans une librairie
bonsoir et merci
[Musique]
Public Sénat en partenariat avec le
Centre national du livre vous a présenté
au bonheur des livres
[Musique]